Russia's foreign ministers warning the
United States about taking military
action against Syria over a possible
plan for a chemical weapons attack
Syrian President Bashar Assad inspected
Russian warplanes yesterday at an
airbase in western Syria in eastern
Syria a CBS news crew joined a group of
American troops working to make villages
cleared of Isis safe the fight to oust
Isis from the city of Raqqa is
intensifying Holly Williams is in cabana
Syria just north of the group stronghold
Holly good morning good morning
officially there are around five hundred
US troops here in Syria for the fight
against Isis though the real number is
thought to be much higher and yesterday
we met some of them just 12 miles north
of Raqqa the so-called ISIS capital
these Marines and army engineers have
spent three days camped in the desert
replacing a shattered bridge destroyed
when Isis fled the area two months ago
in the nearby village of a libera they
told us when Isis left they vowed to
haunt this place for another 70 years
perhaps what they meant are the deadly
mines that the extremists planted around
the village where Isis had positions
captain Bobby Murray based at Camp
Lejeune North Carolina said his team is
now working with the villagers to clear
the area ones that are out in the fields
that are visible they'll point them out
to us as we go by and if we if we're
going by and we see them we'll help
dispose of them just minutes later a
truck hit a mine less than a mile away
and the Marines raced off to investigate
the driver miraculously was still alive
medic Colton Segal treated him for
lacerations and concussion Halil bazan
is a fighter with America's Syrian
allies and said he was heading to the
frontline when his vehicle was thrown in
the air the Marines later found more
mines and detonated them winning hearts
and minds in the Middle East will never
be easy for the US but the callous
brutality of Isis has at least for the
moment made it a little easier the
villages in a la barra were too
frightened to speak to us on camera
because they still have family members
living under Isis control but after half
a decade of civil war they told us they
are in desperate need of running water
food and education for their children
Nora incredible reporting Holly Williams
in Syria thank you so much